(pulsing music)
- Since 2012, we have
been based in Savute.
I just want to walk you through
the reason why we ended up there
and how that kind of led into
the making of Savage Kingdom.
Botswana is a land locked county
right in the heart
of Southern Africa.
Chobe National Park is in
the northeastern corner
and it's a particularly dry
and fairly arid environment.
It's almost semi-desert
and what that
really means is that
water is always at a premium
especially in the dry season.
But Savute was a particularly
interesting place
in that the river that
flowed into that area
is an ephemeral river
and it only flows for 20
years in every hundred.
Its name translates as
unpredictable because,
and it's apt because
nobody really knows
when it will arrive or when
it will disappear again.
Now that unpredictability is
due to a number of events.
The catchment area
where the rain falls
that flows down into that area
is about a thousand
kilometers away.
And on its long
journey getting there
it has to break through
several fault lines
and these fault lines
sometimes block the flow
and sometimes release it.
And then Savute
being so dry and arid
it relies quite heavily in also
the micro climates
around the area.
If there's good
rainfall around Savute
and in the dry riverbed
leading up to Savute,
all of those factors
come together
and only then does the river
actually flow into this area.
When it does reach Savute and
when it flows into that area
it empties out into the
bed of an old ancient lake
and really just brings
that back to life.
It forms this incredible oasis
in the middle of the desert.
And when it's at its full,
Savute is probably one
of the most incredible
wildlife habitats,
habitat that would rival,
any of the wildlife habitat,
great wildlife habitats
we have in Africa.
When I was a child I saw the
drying up of the channel,
it disappeared completely
and that was 35 years ago.
But it did return and in 2008,
the river flowed
back into Savute.
In 2012, once the area
had responded somewhat,
we decided to move our
entire filming operation
into Savute for obvious reasons.
After several years
of being there
we did two films on lions,
a film on a leopard family.
In 2014, we started to see that
the area was
starting to dry out.
All those factors that
enabled it to flow
slowly sort of went out of sync
and a big drying up
process was beginning.
We started noticing
that a lot of the herds,
the big herds that
are gathered there
just started to naturally
move off literally
to greener pastures
and that presented a
problem for the predators.
Now, the predators were
stuck in that habitat.
They were bound by their
territorial boundaries,
they couldn't leave.
They were sort of thrust
into the situation.
And I very soon started
to recognize that
this incredible
storm was brewing.
We had a number of
predator families
that were being forced into
an untenable situation.
They were being pushed and
forced in on top of each other
and that really was the
premise and the seed
that pushed forward
the whole concept for
the Savage Kingdom itself.
What was going to happen
when Africa's top predators
were thrust into a confined area
and most of their resources
were gonna be taken away?
Let's have a peek.
(thunder rumbles)
- [Narrator] One
kingdom, five heroes.
Each with a unique power.
Fighting,
not just to survive.
(growling)
But to reign supreme
over the savage kingdom.
(dramatic music)
- Tonight I'm gonna walk you
through sort of round one,
the first season of Savute's
own real life Game of Thrones.
A season of diminishing habitat
and a number of
predator families that
were literally
fighting to survive
and exist in that
particular area.
From the onset, we knew that
this was not gonna
be an easy ride.
These groups of predators
were being forced into this
really untenable situation
and it wasn't going to be a
story about Bambis and rainbows.
Knowing the circumstance
and wanting to be true
to that whole dynamic,
we were really determined
to capture life
as it unfolded in front of us
no matter how harsh and brutal
and difficult it became.
I have a bugbear about
natural history films that
sanitize predators
and what they do.
I think that people
overlook they are predators
and they're doing
what is so natural.
It's not for us to
pull away from it
and I think that the
more that you pull away
from the reality
of what they do,
the less you care for them,
the less you bind to their lives
and emotionally invest in them.
We were determined to show
a sort of honest account
of the way these
predators really live
unaffected by people.
No human pressure was involved.
Just a purely natural
circumstance that
was playing out
and how hard each one
of these predators
had to fight just
in order to survive.
Before we go into more about
the Savage Kingdom and
the dynamic,
I'd like to introduce the
team that helped me film this.
Obviously we had several
family groups to follow.
We had two prides
of lion, a wild dog,
a leopard mother and
a clan of hyenas.
And so, we needed multiple
crews if we were going to
embed in the area and have
a crew per animal family.
This is Rich, he is
my right hand man
who Geoff was talking about.
He's a childhood friend
and he's our longest
serving cameraman.
And then there's a crazy kid,
crazy American kid.
He's from LA.
He gave up his life in the city
and decided to move out
into the wild with us.
Very passionate, very driven
and a lovely, lovely guy.
Then there's Lawrence, he's
my cousin, that's not me.
He is a Botswana bred bush
wreck kind of like I am.
And the adjusting,
for him adjusting
to living out in the
wild and the bush skill
is quite, came very easy to him.
He's a great asset to the team.
And then there was
long, tall, thin Cam
who is a bit of a
wary Australian guy
and I knew him
for about 20 years
and I knew at home in Oz
he didn't really
bath everyday anyway.
So, him joining us, you know,
would have been such an
easy transition for him.
(audience laughing)
I wanna start by saying that
being a cameraman
for the NHFU for us
is very much modeled
on what I learned to do
and how I grew up.
And it's quite a difficult job.
If it is always your
life it comes naturally
but for guys who
are not used to it
it's quite a task.
You have to be bushman, tracker,
you have to be cook, you have
to be pretty much everything.
And then you've got,
on top of that
you've got to spend
month on end living
out in the wild
just following, endlessly
following animals.
Month on just keep going.
And it takes a very specific
type of character to do that.
And I think fundamentally, you
have to be an animal lover.
If your enthusiasm
is about animals
and following your story and
loving their behavior,
the camera work kind
of comes secondary.
As long as you can do that
you can spend the amount
of time that you need to
to get what you want.
It wasn't all just lying around.
You know, it was long hours.
Lions used to, they sleep
for most of their lives.
80% of their time
they're asleep.
You will spend days
watching them sleep
just to capture a 15-minute
piece of interaction
on the fourth day,
and it's quite exhausting.
And you have to be fairly
comfortable in your life
and clearly Cam because
he wasn't showering.
Anyway, but there's
a point in which
everybody starts to
go a little bit crazy
and you start having your own
little docudrama in the car.
You sort of fight wars and
you do all sorts of things
and everybody at some point
just gets a little bit manic
and a little bit crazy.
And start doing some
particularly stupid things,
particularly Cam.
Everybody seems to lose
the plot at some point
but very quickly
we regain it and
you know, kick them in the line
and they start focusing
on the job again.
One of the things
that is so important
to getting a behavior and
working with these animals
is you've got to get these
animals to really trust you.
Now we had been
there for three years
before the Savage
Kingdom started
and a lot of these
animals really started
to become acclimated to us.
And as you can see they would
use our car as shade so often.
That's how comfortable
they became with us
and it's important
thing to do with animals
that they can play
out their normal lives
without you feeling like
you're influencing them.
Only then can we really immerse
ourselves into their lives
and let them just get
on with it unencumbered.
Now, some of you would
have noticed that our cars
we paint with zebra stripes.
I know it's the
Botswana national animal
but we really do that because
it's cool, we're
young, we're hip.
(audience laughing)
We wanna be different
and we wanna be
noticed, you know?
Most of that's not true.
The only thing that
is true about that
is that we do wanna be noticed.
Most animals and predators
only see in black and white
and there are a lot
of other vehicles
that would come
through that area,
tourists would be
traveling through
and what we wanted to
do is make ourselves
instantaneously recognizable
to the characters that
we're working with.
That they could at a glance know
that we were there
and they trusted us
and they were completely
comfortable with
us having around,
and they knew that we weren't
going to impede on their lives
while they hunted
and what they did.
And it so often happened
where we would be
working with a leopard,
she would go and she would
lie down in the tree.
It's getting a bit hot, she'd
given up hunting for the day
and she would get up and we'd be
80, 90 meters away from her.
She'd get up and she'd literally
walk straight to the car,
crawl underneath our
car and go to sleep
or lie right next to us.
They would choose to come to us.
They sort of trusted us enough
and it was just an indication
of how well that plan worked
and how accustomed they were
to us and us being around.
From a childhood
fascination with predators
to a adult familiarity
with predators.
Andy and I were talking recently
and in the past 20 years or so,
I've spent more
time with predators
than I have with people.
I am fascinated about their
level of intelligence.
I am completely passionate about
spending time with
these animals.
Each one of them develop,
each species develops
a unique skillset
that they use in very
different ways to each other.
And even beyond that,
specific individuals will
actually develop a skillset
that is specific to
that particular animal.
That is just an indication of
the level of intelligence
that these animals have
and it's what really drives me.
The fact that I can be with
predators out in the field,
they adapt, they
change, they anticipate
and there's nothing more
exciting than knowing
that at any point in
the day, at any time,
that animal may do something
that nobody has ever
witnessed before,
nobody's ever seen before.
And that's really what drives me
and what keeps me out there
and keeps me wanting to
be with these animals.
Now for some slightly
more serious side
to this whole thing.
The one thing that all these
predators have in common is
they have to kill
in order to live.
It's exhilarating,
it's exciting,
it's a very primal,
almost gladiatorial
kind of instinct that they have.
And I really, I'll
go back to this point
that I really feel that
people are very quick to judge
and I don't shy away from it.
I think that we have
to get accustomed
to the reality of their
lives and embrace it,
and know that it's
completely natural.
It's not gratuitous.
It's not for any other reason
than just pure survival
and it's very natural,
and I think we should become
more and more accepting to it.
I don't think that, I
mean hyenas as you know
have got a really bad rap.
And they're sometime
referred to as evil
and they're sometime referred
to as horrible or bad
but you know, it's not for
us to lay that on them.
That's a human construct.
They're just doing what they
are naturally designed to do,
what they are born
to do to survive.
Game of Thrones,
Geoff eluded to it
and what the comparison
with that was.
We were in a finite environment.
We had a series
of different clans
that were fighting it
out to take ownership
or just to exist or to
own that piece of land.
And when we are trying to
explain this concept to people
the minute we reference
Game of Thrones
it became a shorthand.
They understood exactly
what it is about
and it became a shorthand
for us to try and
explain the whole concept
and how we wanted to
treat this project.
We were after predator conflict
and that is
certainly what we got
during our time
with Savage Kingdom.
In 15 months of filming,
we saw 28 different war scenes
where one clan
conflicted with another.
One or other
combination of predators
actually came together and
literally fought it out
for ownership or for a kill
or for possession of
a particular area.
And the parallels between
what is happening there
and Game of Thrones
you can obviously
start to see that link.
We thought it was a
particular stroke of genius
to ask Charles Dance to.
He was one of the leaders
of one of the clans
in Game of Thrones
and we thought that bringing
him in to narrate it for us
would really help that
concept and help that project.
Charles was very
intrigued by the way
that we want to treat it.
He really supported it and
was very interested in the way
and what we were trying to
achieve with this project.
And during the narrating
part of it when in the studio
he also seemed to have
quite a lot of fun
and let's take a look.
- I am life.
(thunder rumbles)
I am death.
I give everything.
But I take all.
(dramatic music)
I am the Savage Kingdom.
The old queen is dead.
Now the greatest hunter
takes the throne.
She leads the most
brutal army in the realm.
Matsumi.
How was that?
Well, I'm not doing it again.
(dramatic music)
- Charles was
great to work with.
We felt that his voice
had a lot of gravitas
and had a lot of gravitas to it,
and with his skill he was able
to add a lot of nuance into
the way that we wanted
to portray this film.
And also give it very much
a sort of feature feel to it
in the very much scripted drama
type of delivery
that we were after.
Savage Kingdom really became
a perspective piece for us.
We are following five
different family groups
and each of the
episodes we try to tell
from that particular
family's point of view.
We buy into, we wanted
the audience to associate
with a heroine, with a
character and a family
and go on their journey.
Know what they wanted to do,
what their ambition was,
their path, their
life, their struggle.
And at some point they
were gonna cross with
these other predators.
And inadvertently
they became the enemy
and then that all gets
turned on its head
when you now watch an
episode that was from
the so-called
enemy's perspective
and the whole dynamic shift.
We are not comfortable
with the whole
anthropomorphism idea
and we try to deliberately
avoid it in a lot of our films.
We feel that...
Well, the problem is is that
we still wanted people to
emotionally invest
in your characters
and invest in those people.
Invest in those characters
and invest in their story.
What we did is we introduced a
second person voice
or a proxy voice
that we used as a
sort of emotional step
just to kind of
navigate you through
the sort of, what
those animals wanted,
their intent, their
instincts, their drive
without actually
being anthropomorphic.
And we think it
really, really worked
and Charles bought into that
idea really, really well
and he executed it
incredibly well.
We couldn't have asked for
a better delivery from him.
An example of that is Saba
who I'll introduce
you to shortly,
one of our main characters.
She had a set of cubs
and she used to leave them
on leopard rock.
And it acted as a
nursery for her cubs
while she was out hunting.
And just that drive with her
wanting to return to her cubs,
that second person
voice just gave you
that anxiety and that drive
and it just helped
you contextualize
their lives in human terms.
Names, a lot of the names that
we have adopted in the film
were names that already existed
for a lot of the
characters out there.
They are names that
guides in the area
and people had given them
and most of the time
they were functional,
they earned their names.
They were descriptive
of their character
or of an area that they lived in
or some behavior trait,
behavioral trait
that they used to do.
It definitely wasn't
an idea to make them
into little people
but it gave us the shorthand
to be able to identify
with individuals
within this greater battle.